[Musik]
durch
b
[Musik]
herr bundeskanzler aus ihrer kanzlerzeit
gibt es einige bilder die im allgemeinen
gedächtnis haften bleiben
eines davon stammt aus dem september
1984 wo sie ihn verbal mit
staatspräsident fans beim klar zuerst
einige kriegsgräber besucht haben das
war glaube ich erst einmal das vertrauen
und mit frau sein französischer
staatspräsident auf einen deutschen
soldatenfriedhof gegangen ist da gibt es
aber dieses eine bild wo sie zusammen
vor einem sack stehen und sie halten die
hände
wer hat wem die hand gereicht man muss
vielleicht um dieses bild zu verstehen
noch ein wort zur vorgeschichte sagen
im sommer 1984 war der vierzigsten
jahrestag der invasion in der normandie
front wobei die franzosen immer sagen
zwar gar keine invasion zehnjährige
befreiung frank er aber wie stark es bei
unserem sprachgebrauch und damals gab es
den diskussionen in frankreich ist nie
verstanden haben
ich müsse dorthin war die britische
königin der amerikanische präsident also
die sieger des zweiten weltkriegs ich
kam damals ich glaube über eine von der
blauen uns getroffen zu haben
besprechung und aber von einer sehr
unglücklichen verfassung weil die
zeitungen schrieben haben überreden
fonds war sein freund helmut und so
weiter und habe ich ihm gleich gesagt
und so mache ich nicht
ist jemand beim platz in diesem auch
unglücks ist für die sieger des zweiten
weltkriegs eine wichtige erfahrung aber
millionen deutsche haben eine andere
erinnerung ich wir uns auch denn dort
ist mein bruder der später noch gefahren
ist zum ersten mal für verwundet worden
ich kann definitiv nicht hin
es hat auch sofort akzeptiert dass es
ähnlich empfunden und der name darüber
gesprochen wir müssten doch eine solche
geste machen und dann sagte er
jenes dann sagte ich wohl noch
weitergehen
das hat einen grund beim aus unseren
gegenwärtigen erzählen wussten wer sehr
schwammig ist auf dem rückzug
anfang juni 1940 durch die fliegen dort
verwundet worden
bankchef gerade um mein vater war mir
super kriegs in der ganzen welt schlacht
in dem ganzen hier sind in der schlacht
monate lang und seine brüder übrigens
auch mit werden für unter eine rolle
gespielt da verwickelt und deswegen nach
wetter und schult die geschichte
entstanden dann haben wir die kinder
beiden tages waren die 20.000 eingeladen
veteranen aus dem ersten weltkrieg
dazu dann dort standen war das eine
unglaubliche atmosphäre da waren diese
tausende schulkinder die praktisch gar
nicht zu halten waren mit diesen
kilometer langen kleber feldern will ich
nicht darüber nachdachten dass der putz
trainer bekommen dann die war zu weit
weg vom werden des kriegs wie wir in
unserem schulzeiten über die pässe
kriege geredet haben
und dann waren gleichzeitig die
federraten ich weiß mir stand ernst
jünger der letzte träger lebende träger
des polymer it hast du im ersten
weltkrieg in frankreich
heckmann 10 nehmer stammt und viele
alten kommandos des ersten und des
zweiten weltkriegs und diesem augenblick
hat er so platt gesagt da haben fassung
von ihm aus dieses bild hat für mich
sehr viel bedeutet aber für ihn auch er
dass er später in eine plakette schlagen
lassen nach dem recht des französischen
präsidenten
und er war eigentlich bis an sein
lebensende glücklich dass dieses bild
gab
was haben sie persönlich für sich in dem
moment empfunden
es war ein vergnüglicher um ein bisschen
von verbänden zu bewusster dort
glücklich wissen sie es ist ja nicht
nachvollziehbar gewesen wenn man die
geschichte von 1914 bis 1984 betrachtet
das ihren zwei weltkriegen gegeneinander
gezogen sind und dass ich erwarte er
eine absolut ins absurde überzogene
militärmaschinerie etabliert hatte wo
man praktisch nicht die planer im krieg
umgebracht wurden nach vielen sondern
berechnet wie viel verlust an kraft
eines volkes indem ganze nacht ganze
generation geworden sind das bedeutet
und wenn sie das einmal bezogen auf den
ersten weltkrieg denen es ist ja nicht
nur die richtige zahl junger leute sie
brauchen ja nur in ein normales noch
nicht überlebt dass die nachsuche müssen
gebäude über latin krieg ziehen und sie
und an der universität und sehen die
zahl der gefahrenen ersten und zweiten
weltkrieg damit sieht die sind natürlich
gefallen aber sie haben noch keine
familie gegründet
sie haben keine kinder erzeugt haben
nichts weiter leben dürfen und das war
es für mich immer wieder wenn ich wieder
vorbeikommen
das springt einförmig an das ist ihr
sind uhr und in dem weinhaus oben wir
waren ja dann an dem museum ist es ja
was besonders dort ziemlich wohl sagen
dass ich erleben durfte sind bei
klinsmann vaters erlebt dass ich erleben
durfte
dass wir zweiter stammt und wir wussten
was wir wollten und dachten es wäre
völlig deckungsgleich
das war für uns beide eine große stunde
sagt wahrscheinlich auch ihre beziehung
noch gefestigt enorm gelistet sind keine
frage unsere beziehung waren eben nicht
nur die politischen beziehungen des
tages das wasser auch
und was hat er nie gesagt ich freue mich
trotzdem über frankreich hätte die
inkarnation gewesen
der wusste schon natürlich ganz genau
sein vorteil wahrzunehmen schiff an land
so wie ich auch aber dieses aufeinander
angewiesen seien
das war eben das was du ablösungen und
war ihre zeit der kanzler das war ja
auch geprägt von vielen persönlichen
freundschaften und die helfen ja dann
auch in der politik eine sicherlich
geholfen
in der zeit der einheit
wir haben drei amerikanische präsidenten
wegen bush und clinton war die
freundschaft mit 1 3 gleich oder was
anders oder zwei und drei verschiedene
männer aber zwar war das heißt was ist
also dran leben hier noch leiden rund
regen sehr krank in eine wirkliche
freundschaft geworden
in dohna trinken das begann für mich
sehr günstig ich konnte überhaupt nicht
ich war oppositionsführer
er war extra nach galt als
präsidentschaftskandidat diese
bescheiden leute nahmen in bonn die
sowas auch in emden prüfen kampf
vergeblich der wird nie gewählt folglich
hat ihm keiner in bonn einem termin
gegeben und da bin ich gefragt worden
mich hat der mann ein geschenk der
präsidentschaft interessiert sondern was
vorher ein paar sachen als kann man
eingang von ihm gemacht das hat mich
interessiert da war er da als kandidat
von autos trecker keine rede
und dann haben wir uns unterhalten und
das war zählte dieses gespräch er hat
gar kein hehl daraus gemacht dass er
überhaupt keine ahnung von europäischen
dingen hatte habe aus kalifornien von da
an und vereint auf der passivseite der
vereinigten staaten und dann hat es
gespräche so gut gelaufen dass ich einen
termin rausgeschnitten haben uns richtig
intensiv unterhalten über die dauer
zuteilung soll übrigens ein permanentes
thema eine ganze zeit sieht
und da dieser präsident geworden
und dann hatte ich wenn sie so wollen
einen glänzenden einstand hat nie
vergessen dass sie das amtliche born
über den für die schulter geguckt und
alter hat mit ihm geredet für uns der
gleiche satz man sieht sich im leben
zwei machen und dann hat er ist das ein
sehr intensives gespräch immer gewesen
und eine sache war dominiert
er mag die deutschen werte überhaupt
keine aversion obwohl er mit bestimmten
kreis des jüdischen weltkongresses in
hollywood und anderswo viele beziehungen
hatte die die stören und zu unseren
gunsten sprachen da war seine position
eindeutig und vor allem denkt immer
daran wenn ich am brandenburger tor
stehen
durchlaufen für ihn war der satz herr
gorbatschow öffnen sie dieses tor kein
pr trick für ihn war eine teilung
deutschlands indiskutabel
er wollte dass das werk so formuliert
sie ist als wenn man ein kleines stück
abstreitet auch in der körper weiter
liegt der nächste works bush den kannte
ich natürlich den bruder vizepräsident
war beim schuss kommt hinzu und ich
ausdrücklich sagen
laura bush eine fantastische vor auch
diesmal wenn einer was hat sich der bis
zum heutigen tag versteht und die auch
wenn sie nach deutschland kamen da war
das herz ganz offen und zwar zwischen
dieter schneider nie möglich gewesen
ohne hunger trinken und seine politik
der eindämmung seine politik der über
richtung mussten die sowjets ins joch
zwingen
ökonomisch dann ihren kollaps wieder bei
für das nicht möglich gewesen und george
bush hat dann eigentlich auch durch die
kunden zu uns gehalten wenn man sich
zwar über das thema reden
und bei dem dritten bei beginn der 12
sehr schwierig für mich am anfang weil
ich ja klarer parteigänger von george
bush war
beide präsidenten waren ich habe auch
nie einen hehl daraus gemacht wie kam
ich dazu bush war immer zu uns gestanden
und ich bin dafür dass man die freunde
nicht vergisst und dabei die erste
begegnung und knistert es um
wissensstand ja schon die zeitung
da habe ich ihm gleich gesagt die
beginner präsident bevor wir anfangen
bevor mitarbeiter kommen wenn er nur die
dolmetscher dabei lassen sie uns über
unsere beziehung ganz offen reden
sie wissen nicht wahr sein freund von
mir einmal freunde unseres landes hat
alles getan ich war nicht hier unterwegs
so mich zurückzuhalten sonne gesagt
dieser präsident ist uns das richtet
sich gegen sie als person aber das war
meine position des wildes verstehen und
das gespräch ist dann hatte ganz offen
auch angesprochen da so alles gesehen
hatte
im zweiten teil zu ihm gesagt dass man
über uns reden die wissen ja nur von mir
aus den akten und den berichten und wir
wissen so gut wie ich wie viel dummes
zeug da steht das ist uns das schildern
wo ich herkomme von herkommen elternhaus
und so weiter und so seine eigene war es
keine einfache jugend gehabt
dann war das gespräch bin ich offen
dann haben wir unsere delegation
gespräche gemacht die später die
mitarbeiter man zitate verblüfft dass
gar keine spannung da drin war und am ab
dachte messen sagt werden bevor wenn sie
sowohl der durchbruch
er sagte zu mir ob ich noch mal mehr
zeit hat dazu bleiben sagte ich ja als
begründung kam mit einer älteren dame
sagte dass meine mutter
und ja von ihrer mutter zählt und dann
hat sie bei uns damals so erzählt wie es
meiner mutter gegangen ist im alter wie
man halt normale leute miteinander reden
es war die stunde das beliebte einer
freundschaft manch einer ihrer
mitarbeiter satz mit der sprache da
würde es manchmal bei ihnen seien
ungenau werden insbesondere sodass
gesagt als die einen einmal gorbatschow
als publication mann bin und es war eine
riesendummheit dass das wahrsagen das
waren hintergrund gottes interviewt das
trifft mich man einfach nicht noch mal
nachdenken lieber lesen ist etwas
kleiner gemacht du hast passiert diesem
geschäft ich habe später dafür
entschuldigt dass es auch hat uns darauf
später gar nicht mehr sonderlich berührt
da es ist ja auch eine persönliche
beziehung was die überhaupt nicht aber
wirklich wirklich vorhersehbar war habe
ich vorher versucht bevor er am kontakt
zu kriegen aber wie immer abgeriegelt
worden und dabei bietet der serie von
beerdigungen breschnew an bord von
dungeon ingo da habe ich ihn eigentlich
zum ersten mal richtig gesehen und
gesprochen und da waren wir noch sehr
weit auseinander und im laufe der
gespräche habe ich ihr mehrmals
gebrochen
dann hat sich das verbessere dieser
respektvoll geworden
aber damals war der einzug von von toni
kroos sehr stark wir waren der promi
kowallik auf dem dampfer wer über
deutsche einheit rede design
kriegstreiber das hat dann einfach den
fall aufgeklärt
das eigentliche gespräch mit welcher
gewerkschaft der durchbruch weil hier
auch allerlei da waren 219
89 es war die zeit wo die leute gorbi
gorbi überall in deutschland lebender
feiern und populär wie kaum ein anderer
mit recht und perestroika und die kommen
zu veränderungen ins haus stünden
und damals war da meine frau mit der
wirtschaft drüben am buga logistischen
wir saßen da unten auf der mauer
das ist diese berühmte szene der server
veröffentlicht hat deswegen redet
darüber
ich hab das lange nicht getan und das
war schon sehr eigenartig nur die
dolmetscher und und waren die liebespaar
wie tief danach dass er stand waren es
hat viele stunden da damals zum ersten
mal geredet wie wahlleiter war die rede
von einem vertrag gedanken des großer
vertrag zwischen bundesrepublik unsere
union um ganz am ende kamera nicht
straff zurück wir waren ziemlich weiten
von überlegungen und sagt ihm aber
wirken macht was die systeme der
deutschen einheit spät
und natürlich war ich weiter von dem wir
glauben dass das morgen passiert wenn
sie mich an dem abend gefragt hätte ich
gesagt ob ich das erlebe weiß ich nicht
ob ich die panda lebe bin ich sicher
dass ich nicht erleben zwar im sommer
980 und damals hat er dann war dieses
zitat sich intakte der fluss der
reingeht hier verwandte königstein
aber dieses wasser kommt ins meer
die deutschen wollen kommt die deutsche
einheit wann immer das ist so wenn sie
sind erstaunt dass schlägt das ufer das
war das erste mal dass er nicht
widersprochen hat
und vielleicht war der dieb wirkung die
später geradezu beachtet wird auf mir
nicht dass er damals erst mal ganz offen
darüber sprach dass er größte
versorgungsschwierigkeiten ab wir haben
das zwar gelesen aber dass er selber
sagt und sozusagen zugibt dass man ein
und dann hat er darüber gesprochen ob
wir helfen würden und das haben wir dann
einige monate später geplante spitze den
kuriositäten
das war schlecht angelegte geld der
republik in dieser zeit als danach der
sowjetunion zucker butter und die wahl
hatten hart nato vorrat geliefert haben
und dass die deutschen großen kaufhaus
konzerne dass man sie allerdings dann
bezahlt dieser weg bist mal in großer
zahl stammen schuhe schlüpfen flachen
geliefert haben und glücklich die regale
kinofilm ausgabe der folge dessen auch
so wirkungen die man erleben kann
ihre erfahrung ist dass die persönliche
beziehung unglaublich viel aus wir haben
immer mit ihrem privaten leben die
anderen leute geöffnet ja ich hab das ja
dann sehr bewusst gemacht leute meine
heimat zu holen
und dass man darüber gelästert
aber ich kann nur sagen die wirkung vom
speyerer doms ungeheuer groß sagt also
der saas und paas pur sagte zu mir bin
ich mit den deutschen in europa
romanische dom spricht für sich dass ich
sie nicht seine war jetzt des glaubens
aber sie ist eben nicht irgendein blatt
die keine autofabrik oder so etwas
sondern es ist ein denkmal der baukunst
des christlichen abendlandes und vieles
andere mehr
und ich habe auch die erfahrung gemacht
wenn sie in dem persönlichen umfeld
begleitens eben dass sie ganz anders
zwischen privaten ja nicht anders
ein kleiner chef der neuen in der neue
leute einstellt versuchte auch wenn er
nicht ganz dumm ist etwa die frau
kennenzulernen die als privat
deklarierten angesprochen jetzt ist ja
einer der sie auch um rat gefragt hat
wahrscheinlich aufgrund ihrer sehr viel
längeren politischen erfahrung wenn es
um russische dinge gehen zum beispiel um
die parlamentswahl parlament auflösen
93 und haben sie da ganz offen mit ihm
gehört wie mit einem anderen politiker
er morgens mit kommt zu einer geschichte
wie der boris hat dem kann sich als den
der gegen den gorbatschow so zusammen
auf sprach und deshalb bin ich gefallen
ich war ich weiß ja was ich komme was
wir gorbatschow zu verdanken haben neben
busch oder mit bushido wurde die mieter
kleiner gar nicht denkbar gewesen wäre
aber bei dem ich habe ihn kennengelernt
und als es dann mit den putsch war haben
wir miteinander telefoniert und bush hat
telefoniert und er hat ja dann unsere
stimmen überspielen lassen auf dem platz
damit die leute sehen die welt guckt sie
und dann war die erfahrung mit ihm einen
ganz wichtigen punkten
daran haben die schrift ist die ganze
zeit bedeutet es ein absolut
verlässlicher mann ich habe jetzt sich
jeweiligen politik zu reden aber es gab
immer wieder stationen wo er nichts zu
entscheiden müssen
film auf einen punkt früher zurückgehen
84 war sie mit mitten im wahlkampf 85 85
war das datum für gianna kriegsende
sie hatten vorgeschlagen dass
sondergleichen im bundestag reden sollte
dagegen war bundespräsident von
weizsäcker weil er reden wollte sie sind
dann mit range trading unter anderem
nach bitburg gegangen
das war ja eine geschichte die sehr
diskutiert wurde auch die kritisiert
wurde weil man bei der ersten
besichtigung nicht festgestellt hatte
dass da auf leiter der waffen-ss lagen
warum sind sie eigentlich nicht nachdem
man das erkannt hatte von diesen
pflanzen getreten wir weiter planen ganz
anders wahr wir dann abgelaufen
wenn sie von der wenn man hier von einem
fehler sprechen wir die unity die natur
zu gehen und kriegsregionen stammt ja
von mama drücken
er war angeregt von der cd in werde
anfangs machen jahre deutschland und
dann haben die amerikaner etwas
vorgeschlagen was ich schwöre ich freue
mich nicht ohne papiere
aber die regel von einem künftigen
besuch ich habe dauernd angezweifelt
weil ich glaube dass der präsident der
vor allem stammen sondern kommt und in
unserem programm war der beginn der
besuch des konzentrationslagers dachau
weiß dass nicht nachträglich so gedreht
war der damm der das problem dieses
besuches und das sollte besucher war ist
damit ganz präsent kommt ja nicht der
kopf einer riesenmaschine und mindestens
eine mindestens oder zwei mit
journalisten und wie könig 400 oder 500
journalisten weg baums probieren sie
müssen in der nähe des flughafens seien
und dadurch dass dann der der besuch
gekappt wurde er für zwei tage zu jean
carlos sainz spanien fehlten uns
elemente dieses besuches und bitburg hat
das seinen grund
der ist auch gar nicht bestritten worden
erst mal ein riesiger technischer grund
flughafen wo die großen maschinen des
präsidenten und seinen kontrahenten
konnten
zweitens das war für mich sehr wichtig
bitburg war es vermutlich heute noch der
ort mit den meisten
deutsch-amerikanischen herbert zusammen
mit den meisten deutsch amerikanischen
kindern die dort auf die welt gekommen
sind um mit einem friedhof die den ball
aber nicht mehr ss soldaten liegen auto
fahren es gibt keinen deutschen
soldatenfriedhof in dem kleinen graben
liegen er will sie den bonner friedhof
betrachten nur jahrelang die besucher
waren
werden sie die gartenfest im dritten
bloß darüber niemand geschrieben und
dann und das gehört zu den dingen
ich bin zu heutigen tag ich akzeptiere
wahrhafte im amerikanischen auf dem
soldatenfriedhof war nicht also
irgendeine gruppe von ss-leuten sondern
die gefallene der innovative des
kriegsendes fast leider ganz junge junge
leute keine leute mit hohen rängen und
erzählt am 23 jahre später im
amerikanischen senat darüber
diskutierten mit den senatoren aus
verschiedenen ausschüssen habe ich ein
begann amerikanischen synagoge fakten
aber wenn diese jungen leute nicht
gefallen wären am ende des krieges und
wären davon gekommen während sie in
einem sommercamp gekommen dann wird
angeguckt worden was habt ihr das
gemacht und da wären sie an weihnachten
45 unter der jugend an ist sie gefallen
die der amerikanische opfer vierter zwei
die alten mauer dann fängt hatte und
wären hand gekommen wäre als studentin
irgendwas geworden
jetzt bin ich gar nicht sagen wer alles
was geworden ist bei der waffen als
ressort jünger war
wer in den vereinigten staaten die
großen respekt empfangen worden
diese sache gehört zu den in farmen
erfahrungen meines lebens oder war noch
ganz andere kräfte dabei unterwegs um
daraus als szenario
wer die geschichte genau kennt muss sehr
vorsichtig sein urteil
damals gab es die rede von
bundespräsident leipziger die weltweite
positives echo gab hat die schicht mit
bitburg ein negatives und ist auch eine
zeit wo man merkt dass zwischen dem
bundespräsidenten und dem bundeskanzler
ist zu missstimmung kommt bis zum
schluss ja eigentlich was war der grund
für denkbar
wer liegt es ja gar nicht mich zu
berühren
aber die ersten ganz wichtige geräte zu
diesem thema war die rede
für befreiung des konzentrationslagers
in niedersachsen deren weltweites echo
gefunden und ich kann keine elemente in
einer
man rede entdecken die darüber hinaus
gegangen sind
ich habe mich nie dazu so geeignet in
bestimmten publikationen die gleiche
zustimmung zu finden
wienweit verkauf haben sich eine ganze
menge spannung und ergebnis werden sie
ich habe da kein nach prag zu machen
ich habe ihn gebeten damals hat sich für
den bundestag interessiert hat dass er
ludwigshafen kandidiert auf meinen hund
schienen an dem sich laut delegierung
ist ja akzeptiert er ist dann selbst
nicht bereit gewesen dass beruflichen
gründen das mandat übernehmen aber nicht
kandidiert sondern weniger später in
worms aber der mann der in worms
hilfreich war war der gleiche wie der
vorher in die karten
der gleiche wochen frei stand bei den
bonner ändern und ich habe in einer
dramatischen nacht von sehr schwere
sache meinem engen freund peter lorenz
der ja immerhin die cdu und berlin über
40 prozent gebracht hatte
dazu bewegt mit der begründung du kannst
den durchbruch nicht bekommen in berlin
zurückzutreten richard von weizsäcker
vorzuschlagen
nochmal bis später habe ich noch als
bundespräsident vorstand also wenig als
gelegen schwer da geht es das system
kohl dann kann er lakonisch sagen das
system das kann man kritisieren aber die
den nutzen davon haben ich wollte es
eigentlich nicht regisseur sondern
eigentlich die die daten das system
police gegen nicht gelaufen
das ist so einfach nicht nein wir haben
uns in einer ganzen reihe aufgaben der
deutschen politik besondere meinung
er hat ja aber auch sehr stark das
parteiensystem in deutschland kritisiert
das wird nicht er hat besseres wenn sie
alle die das parteiensystem da kann man
ja viel kritisieren aber wenn man selber
alles durch das system geworden ist
finde ich schon mal eher bescheidenen
anspruch sein was sie sagt ich sofort
und den parteien system das sich genug
bürger mit bahn aber die parteien so
offen
und wenn also ich muss jetzt wollen die
parteimitglieder verteidigen da sicher
nicht viele von sich aus alles
zusammenrechne cdu csu und spd es wir
sind gemeinsam ungefähr gleich stark
weil war zwischen 8 und 9 100 mitglieder
nun kann man die machen auch im job wo
sie nicht dafür kriegen sie gehen also
in die kommunalpolitik die machen und so
die parteiarbeit oder die laut unserer
verfassung und der intelligenz in der
politik die demokratie gar nicht
existieren kann und warum ich jetzt wenn
sie offen sind beschimpfen zu hause sind
sie doch nun offen so keiner gehindert
kann doch jeder die cdu oder die spd
gibt natürlich würde sich schon lassen
der zwar überzeugten dabei wieder finden
ich kann das nicht erkennen kann nicht
erkennen dass sie selbst sehr stark
ich finde nur wer kerze über dieses
system in jedes amt gekommen ist soll
erst mal prüfen ob auf eine andere weise
und dieses amt gekommen wäre und
deswegen wird es klar
nun hat der jetzige bundespräsident
letztes die parteien als etwas na ja das
wort gier ich nicht bewusst aber das
gemeint als es wieder darum ging gelder
vom bundestag zu bekommen weil sie ein
bisschen aufgerundet haben
es gab in den 80er jahren das große
problem dass sie auch die gerichte
beschäftigt hat mit den spenden
erfahrungen klick ist da nicht manchmal
die frage ob die parteien sich wirklich
zu viel geld bekommen ich bin der
meinung das steht nicht aber es ist
richtig
da waren wir alle mit beteiligt fragt es
ausdrücklich aber mein eigener presse
dass wir noch kein system haben aufbauen
können das so zu sagen und sie die lage
versetzt diese dienstleistung die wir in
der politik bringen auch wirklich zu
finanzieren wenn man die flick-affäre
nehmen da hat haben die parteien ja so
getan als wenn sie sich über das gesetz
stellen können
indem sie sozusagen das umgangen haben
die waren damals schon partei eben lange
trocken
mit betroffen aber irgendwann müssen
doch gesagt haben mich nicht richtig
ernst diese rollende gefährt oder von
mir aus dieses nicht richtig wenn man
die medicis zeitabschnitt redet muss
wenn du dich wissen wieder wiederbeginn
der politischen parteien und wenn sie so
wollen der republik nach 45 watt genauer
gesagt 49 und die generation die namens
149 die parteien geführt und begründet
hat natürlich geprägt von der weimarer
republik und die
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten der parteien
der weimarer republik waren total anders
wie heute und ein teil dieser
finanzierungs vorstellungen ist
natürlich aus der weimarer republik auch
in die bundesrepublik übergegangen und
der stadt der parteien war ganz
unterschiedlich die sozialdemokraten
haben zurecht wiedergutmachung bekommen
jetzt aus der alten bundesrepublik weil
sie ihr vermögen hatten halten und was
weiß ich
die an ein startkapital eine partei wie
die fdp die cdu csu oder die fdp war
neugründungen sind verfolgen aus alten
parteien von rob frühjahr aber wir haben
kein vermögen gehabt jetzt in ihren
riesenstadt vorteil capital die uns
wieder hat die spd wieder gutmachen
bekommen von fast 70 millionen nach der
deutschen einheit einer sache durch
unkenntnis darüber nachdenken dass eine
partei die so wenig für die deutsche
einheit nutzungsphase getan hat denn
meist nur wach gemacht hat wir haben
nicht gekommen
bei der spd unter dem signum der
zwangsvereinigung ihr vermögen erst
später bekommen hat die hat von
vornherein zu einer schräg wirkung
geführt zweitens waren die
gewerkschaften auf der seite der spd
stand irgendwie unternehmer die
wirtschaft auf mehr auf der seite von
cdu und fdp
es ist gar keine frage
in den fünfziger jahren aufgewachsen war
und eines gutachtens das des
finanzministeriums ein gewicht bekam da
falsch war
und da ich feiere nun als junge partei
versetzte einer von denen der dagegen an
ging nicht auf und meiner eigenen
überzeugung sondern weil der damalige
finanzminister in einer fraktion wie dem
gatten überprüfung dieser unterlagen
sagte das geht nicht und so bin ich an
eine bestätigung der parteiführer
gegangen wird schatzmeister und aber das
gesagt und das wort aber keine mehrheit
gefunden aber meine äußerung dass dies
nicht der richtige weg ist hat er später
bei den verfahren eine enorme rolle
gespielt ob ein bruch dann da leute die
geld gespendet gutgläubig waren der
fehler war dass man eigentlich nicht den
mut hatte dass man sozusagen bis zuletzt
auszukratzen sagen dass du es jetzt
wirklich mal alles auf den tisch packen
und sagen das ist die regel
dann hält man in seiner regel umgesetzt
treffen müssen aber dafür gab es keine
mehrheit
als sie eigentlich sehr verletzt dass
otto schily die inzwischen innenminister
ist dann auch gegen die strafanzeige
erstattet hatte ein beschädigter mich
nicht verletzen
was für ein genie fällt mir für den rest
ihres lebens nicht mehr kommen wir
nochmal jetzt in ende der achtziger
jahres kommt die der zusammenbruch
eigentlich des sowjetreiches dazu
gehören umwälzungen ja in ganz vielen
ländern eigentlich allen satelliten
ländern
es kommt auch zur umwelt zum in rumänien
couches co haben sie den gekannt hat ja
aber zu den umwälzungen zu denk ich
finde mittel sie wenn man über die
deutsche einheit redet sich gerächt dass
man das war die vorläufer waren dabei
vergisst
ohne den prager frühling werde es keine
entwicklung gegeben
in der zentrum der macht da moskau ein
wetterleuchten horizont oder die
solidarnosc finde es ganz schlimm dass
jetzt in der debatte über den beitritt
in die europäische union mehr
richtigerweise vom geld reden aber nicht
in die geschichtliche leistung der polen
bei der entwicklung auf der deutschen
einheit sprechen ohne den papst der aus
polen kam und er allein als eine bloße
existenz die solidarischen überhaupt
beim burchhardt ermöglicht hat oder die
umgangs dem reformkommunisten pohlers
kommunismus der der da wir mit eröffnung
89 im sommer der ganze im burgenland
höhepunkt fand ohne das wäre das alles
so nicht möglich gewesen und deswegen
finde ich was soll die anderen länder
schon dabei in betracht werden jetzt
bitte noch einmal den zweiten teil des
qualifyings platzwart gehört zu den
schrecklichsten erfahrung meines lebens
ich muss sagen warum soll ich nicht
sagen als ich da eines abends dann
entfernt sind sah die bilder wir dann
tot vor diesem stoff schulgebäude lag
mit seiner frau habe ich aber wirklich
nur mitleid empfunden
ich habe er zwei oder dreimal mit ihm
verhandelt und das gehört zu den
barbarischen erinnerung wissen sie wenn
man so die deutschen vor allem dass die
gegend zieht dann heißt es das ist eine
raubritterburg und einer geschäften wer
die leute gefangenen gegen lösegeld
freigegeben und so kam ich mir vor eine
besondere szene mal in meinem thema im
kanzleramt ab gegenüber direkt und er
daneben es ja doch dauernd reingeredet
tja zf hinterhand gehabt sonst zwar
häufig aber ich lerne so barbarischen
form und dann haben wir wirklich wie in
zug gefeiert
um die kosten für menschen scheibe leute
pseudo preise leute sagt es dafür nicht
machen
nur die rumäniendeutsche sie denke ich
wird zu der gruppe die mehr für ihre für
die tapfer dass die deutsche wagen
gelitten haben und viel am ball
viele haben gelitten und die deutschen
schrecklichen angerichtet aber die
rumäniendeutschen der total seit
generationen dort varna wir deutschen
bewahrt hatten wurden dann 43 42 zur
waffen-ss eingebrochen wie nicht gefragt
wurden sind automatisch zu ziehen weiter
aber bei der waffen fehlte dann in die
viren besonders mit antworten und ihre
frauen sind verschleppt worden
und diese wirklich armen leute wenn man
alles genommen hat ihn dann zur
konservierung was alles war
sie standen an unternahm er hat geredet
der hat abwürfen leute mit abitur fahren
wir so viele leute mit guten zahlen
sowie eine absolut vertraut ist er 100
barbarischer vorstellung
wir haben es getan und wir haben geld
ausgegeben und ich dir heute noch dazu
aber die gier mit der die zweite betrieb
können wer zudem entsetzt
diese zwei war eine wirkliche
heimsuchung der menschheit geld hat
natürlich auch immer in
der einheit im einheitsprozess eine
rolle gespielt sie hat selber gesagt das
beste was wir gorbatschows 980 war dass
wir dort nahrung hingeschickt haben und
so weiter und so fort und die geheimen
gespräche gegeben hat zwischen den
ungarn und ihnen die ging ja auch darum
dass es nicht wir brauchen auch
unterstützung
aber bei den umgang war es schon so dass
dafür nicht vergessen ersten mal war
meine positionieren
die aufnahme politischer der auch in
dieser sache sich große verdienste
erworben habt und kollegen die sagen wir
ja alles vergessen wird ihr habt mir den
ungarn seit geraumer zeit beobachtet wie
darf ich die dinge öffnen
dann haben wir noch einen vorteil ist
eines der wenigen länder mit denen wir
nicht gegen die kriege führt hatten sind
die ungarn immer vom freitag immer mit
uns verloren und haben uns aber nie
verraten
und ich hab dann bei den kontakt an
vermerkte dass sie sich dem sich
verändert habe ich sofort gesagt wenn
wir den wirtschaftlich helfen können das
haben wir uns schon vor den abmachungen
gemacht werden wir es tun und dann hab
ich waren entdeckt als die sache dann im
sommer 89
voran ging jetzt ja gesagt unglaubliche
thesen und sie nachlesen mit das
politbüro der sed darauf reagiert hat
nicht nur die grenzöffnung sondern alles
was dem land gemacht haben
mehrparteiensystem und so david rein
zufällig mitnehmen in einer anderen
sache auch wegen der telefoniert und am
gleichen tag mit gorbatschow in einem
wiederum andere sachen
und dann habe ich ihm erzählt sich jeder
mitnehmen gesprochen
gorbatschow ich habe gorbatschow dieser
ziel und sagte ich wie finden sie den
ich den gorbatschow
dadurch kann wurde
wie sehen denn ich hab mir gefällt es
hier gut aber einen moment stille sagte
das sind gute leute dann habe ich bei
mir gesagt was immer ist der gibt
rückendeckung und silber dann in diese
gespräche gekommen und sie das war der
durchbruch
er hat sich ausgezahlt dass wir die
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft nicht
eingeführt haben also die trennung
staatsbürgerschaft nach der seite nach
der seite die ddr staatsbürgerschaft
nicht oder nur ganz kurz und es gibt nur
deutsch und die wussten schon was sie
machen und dass wir ihnen helfen dass
sich auch war aber warum mag ich nicht
werden sie wenn ich die summe betrachtet
die unter kaltem griechische jahr
gekostet hat was uns die richtung
gekostet hat was uns und der prozess der
deutschen einheit gekostet hat welches
alles gebracht und hat in frieden
gedient ist verwendet man bewusst dieses
wort war es doch ein fantastisches
geschäft dass das wie der bdr dann
schwieriger war das mit dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion und die
märkte weggebrochen sind deshalb kein
mensch bewusst ich habe im sommer 1990
in kiew doch mit cavadov für 30
milliarden eine hermes garantie der
bundesrepublik für lieferung aus den
neuen ländern als erster ddr später neun
ländern in dieser vision der
vereinbarung wir dachten dass wir dann
das niveau halten können dass die
betriebe die noch nicht auf dem niveau
des welt export sind die übergangszeit
schaffen und ich hab auf dem flugplatz
habe ich ihn gefragt damals zu zu wir
uns dann was ist denn mit dem gerücht es
gibt ein putsch er lacht übers ganze
gesicht und sagte es kann zu vergessen
ist die verbalinjurien weglaufen
die werden nico zwei wochen später war
der putsch und sechs monate später war
die sowjetunion zusammengebrochen ist
konnte doch in dieser form gar kein
mensch entdecken aber wenn sie das doch
auch
summe was wir bezahlt haben an die
sowjetunion das alles zusammenrechnen
da kann ich nur sagen wenn uns 1970 den
deutschen gesagt für dieses geld denn
dieses politische ziel erreichen der
verrückt erklärt worden und deswegen ist
es ab und zu mal ganz witzig wieder
daran zu erinnern dass es bei allem was
das gekostet hat wenig geld war und viel
frieden freiheit 89 war innenpolitisch
so dass geißler versuchte sie zu kippen
dass man sagte 1990 ist die
bundestagswahl
die können wir mit helmut kohl gar nicht
mehr gewinnen diejenigen die sie kippen
wollten
auf der anderen seite entwickelt sich
etwas wo sie wahrscheinlich als alter
hase sagen das ist die große chance
sie selber haben den spruch von bismarck
und der zipfel des wandels der
geschichte dem eingreifen muss ja damals
auch zitiert hat dass sie manchmal
beeinflusst wenn sie gedacht haben ich
muss die meinungsführerschaft im
einigungsprozess ergreifen ja also das
geht mir schon früher los wenn sie das
rekapitulieren man muss man doch ehrlich
sagen dass er wenn sie die sogenannte
oberschicht dazu parteien kirchen
gewerkschaften wirtschaft was sie sich
vorstellen leben nicht die breite masse
der bevölkerung war doch in den jahren
nach 1986 der wille zur deutschen
einheit ziemlich geschrumpft und die
bewunderung für die zehn größten
industrienationen der welt so hat er die
propaganda täte der ddr gelautet war
schon ziemlich allgemein unterwegs und
dementsprechend galt gerade wie ich als
ziemlich verrückt der send wurde des
jüdischen weltkongresses eine
organisation die mir besonders langer
zeit besonders nicht gewogen war und ist
vermutlich auch aber das ist eine
ziemlich gleich gelegt
die hat damals dem außen mit da hoffmann
der ddr-regierung als honecker gestürzt
war ist oft ist er zwar und die neue
regierung kam gesagt wann man werde
alles tun um die täter zu erhalten man
dagegen die deutsche einheit
und man solle sich doch nicht nur mit
diesem verrückten ein halbfertiges
bundeskanzler unterhalb des g-ba andere
winter cdu die zwar so also ich bin da
weit davon entfernt das parteipolitisch
zu sehen
und in dieser situation waren schon
wieder licht am horizont zu sehen
für mich eine der bittersten sachen
dieser zeit die zehn jahren den bildern
und wenn sie die viele heute am gucken
war der besuch von eggers bei uns in der
bundesrepublik das war für mich eine
körperliche pein dass ich die fahne und
die nationalhymne sozusagen mit
akzeptieren mussten von organen ein
es war eigentlich mein hauptpunkte
honecker feld veronika maria ersten
treffen das war bei einer der beerdigung
ist ab und an prof
in moskau haben wir uns ganz vernünftig
miteinander reden ist ja praktisch
nachbarn von daher gesehen haben auch
gemeinsame bekannte er als junger mann
vor 35 die bei mir meinen altersabstand
später pfarrer waren in den verein und
darüber unterhalten und ich weiß noch
nicht im sagte gans wenn wir man damit
40 reden wirken könnten die beim abhören
uns nicht verstehen dass von dem moment
war ganz erstaunt dass wir zu lachen
werden profi wetter doch den kopf ran
gegangen
aber bei dem besuch dann ist mir klar
geworden dass er zwei dinge erstens dass
er wirklich nicht mehr kann
unsere informationen zwar nicht sehr gut
sie wissen ja dass die nach dem stoff
brand gespräch bei einer tasse kaffee
und bei dem anderen gespräch sie die
dienste eingestellt hatten
die propaganda bei hinreißend war andere
wussten auch nicht der wert
amerikanischer nachrichtendienste
nach erkundung aus der ddr daher kein
grund zu sagen die wankte mir war
schlecht stimmt einfach nicht
und er hat dann zum ersten mal ganz
offen rausgelassen
wie knapp das alles geworden ist
wir waren an den zweiten abend hier in
bonn das war die sogenannte gegen essen
modell bristol und da fahren wir von
langweilig zu bis das essen bei kam was
wir an dem abend erreicht war
wir waren sozusagen isoliert den kopf
des vereins leider war beim vorgänger
vandermark präsident des bundesrates
hatte philipp jenninger
bundestagspräsident ich habe die beiden
gebeten sich mit ihren ddr leiden nach
der anderen teile zu beschäftigen sagt
zwischen dem mittag und in den
generalsekretären omega und darf sind
die zum ersten mal aus dem loch
ausgegangen
oder mal darüber geredet was sie noch
alles brauche nicht die summen aber das
waren die richtung
da war für mich nun sehr stark
unterstützen französische str das hat er
immer so genau so gesehen es war ein
punkt der gemeinsamkeit vieler in der
union nicht verstanden dass wir sagten
da machen wir es mit geld und dann war
die sich die rechnung
ihr lasst leiter zu besuch aus und
wirken geben darlehen ganz brutal und
das glaube ich war der eigentliche punkt
und die so wenig modi ddr propaganda zu
hause kaputt gegangen ist dass er dann
88 89 millionen ddr bürger hier waren
fiel dann mehrmals
dass der familien die die definition
verbindungslösungen ganz weit hinkel war
plötzlich familien ausgeweitet wird und
das ergebnis war dass ihr verwendet
davon und stellten nicht nur das
westfernsehen das war ich darüber auch
nichts zu sehen
gesehen wurde sondern dass plötzlich die
leute sagten dass ich ja wirklich so ich
habe mit meiner körperlichen wie viele
leute da von den kampfrichtern oder
ludwigshafen am sonntag ab passten und
dann gekommen sind früher waren sie der
ecke gestanden dann gesagt das ist der
bundeskanzler der läuft allein auf der
straße rum also in diese ganz andere
einschätzung der lage
ich glaube das war der durchbruch sie
kommen die leute nicht mehr sagen
hier sind die leute verelenden sondern
sie leben hier liegen während gerade
strauß und kredite angesprochen
sie hat das eigentlich je erfahren dass
sie diesen berühmten milliarden kredite
seien ihm zugespielt habe über schalke
los kostet dort sachen der für mich
gesetzt
der strauß habt ihr selbst gesagt er
habe es eingefädelt jetzt wissen sie er
hat den entscheidenden und sie hatten
dem start gesagt kümmer dich mach ich
nicht sagen lassen was guten grund weil
ich auch ich hätte das als
cdu-vorsitzende springen können im cdu
csu
wenn wir sozusagen von zugriff nicht
dabei gab die sozialdemokraten oder die
fdp habe ich in dieser innerparteiliche
situation überhaupt nichts genutzt
aber nachdem der franzose wie das wasser
gemacht hat immer total gemacht hat und
gleichzeitig die bayerischen banken zu
den führungs banken versuchen derzeit
korrektur zu weniger gekommen
ja also ich brauche geld haben sie
gesagt im weniger der soll zum strauß
gehen ja aber strauss wusste nicht dass
sie das so gesagt dort ist aber später
drüber das war kein staatsgeheimnis
aber wenn sie das überlegen davon zu
sabrina super parteitags ergebnis gab
ein parteitag ergebnis bei der wahl 190
war es entschieden die cdu leute
anfingen am großen vorsitzenden zu
zweifeln dass super angelegtes geld
der deutsche steuerzahler hat ja keine
markt bezahlt wir haben nur den
bankkredit verwehrt wurde so weg das war
normal rüber conti chef insofern finde
ich auch im nachhinein war das sehr gut
und das hat davon zurück ist ganz
entscheidend und saft positive grab mit
einer ungeheuren energie das war ein
thema das ihm gefallen hat jetzt können
wir zur deutschen einheit werden die
grenzen geöffnet ungarn und kommen die
deutschen eher für dramatische sitzen in
der prager botschaft hunderttausende von
deutschen und es wird dann ausgaben
dürfen raus kommen
sie haben glaube ich zu der zeit in
operation gehabt und konnten nicht weg
also genscher fährt nachtrag die damit
er sein so da ist beeindruckt damals
gewesen dass seite sozusagen als
aufpasser mit pferd damit menschen nicht
zu tief und dem ruhm abbekommt
angestellte schlecht wenn man hier im
aufbautraining schicken wollen
in der sache war engagierter finanz viel
zu alter erfahrener vor man also davon
eine scheibe weggelacht wird er hat ja
die verhandlungen geführt
deswegen war ja ganz richtig und erst
wenn ich gekonnt hätte wäre ich nicht
gefahr weil der bus kommt meine in der
situation um eine new yorker zu viel
gewesen lehrer in der optischen wirkung
sie dir nicht vergessen in prag waffe
einer eine statistische gruppe
das war eine völlig unbelehrbare leute
leider mit dem man ja ja bis zuletzt auf
stalins muss festgehalten
auf der anderen seite war die der nackte
zahlen aus berlin
das wäre keine kluge politik gewillt ich
finde das was hier sehr gescheit wie es
gelaufen ist
denn die ddr musste ungeheuer schlucken
an der fachen umgang
das war ja vorher und würden sie nicht
mehr dafür nicht vergessen die
weltöffentlichkeit bei den heutigen
betrachten für die am meisten zweck was
andere gedacht haben
diese deutsch diese deutschen aus
ganztag stammt diese stand in ungarn fix
gesetzt haben und die dann aus dem
schilf bürger neusiedlersee rauskam und
sie knieten das hat janka ungeheuer
warnschuss ich weiß was im test bot
schon andere dass die meisten haus mit
ihren familien gesehen und die senatoren
bei uns immer so eine meinung die
anderen merken das nicht es für ein
amerikaner ist der dritte freiheit ist
irgendwie ein leitbegriff und da waren
leute die sind haben alles liegen stehen
lassen sind so wie sie waren mit kurzen
hosen und mit einem hemd in die freiheit
das eine ungeheure wirkung
es kommt dann der 19 november mit der
abendlichen öffnung der mauer diesen
gerade in polen zu einem ganz wichtigen
staatsbesuch da welchem augenblick an
wie das erfahren dass die mauer hier
noch noch an dem abend das passt in der
nacht ganzes passiert jetzt darauf der
etwa der amanda mitarbeiter an und ich
wollte sie gar nicht gab war ich wusste
dass das alles in bewegung geraten war
aber das ist in der form geht das wusste
ich das wusste ich nicht
und dann hat sich eine ganze ungute
situation entwickelt in prag weil der
stadt dieses jahres gegen einen raschen
entschuldigung bei der staatsregierung
setze denn das ganze zu wieder variieren
anderen auch obwohl es damals eine frei
gewählte regierung war dann in einer
sehr seltsamen weiße darauf bestanden zu
ende geführt werden
und ich habe mit solchen dramatischen
begründung sei zu einem großen empfang
eingeladen und so unsere nämlich einfach
gesagt ich komme wie das hat mir niemand
geglaubt und dann bin ich weg geflogen
und dann waren nur schwierigkeiten
ich durfte die ddr gebiet nicht
überfliegen
ich musste dann den weg über schwer
machen bin ich eine lampe in hamburg
endlich gelandet und da mehr ganze
botschafter ich konnte mit der
bundeswehr maschine nicht nach berlin
bis die maschine nach berlin gegeben
als sie dann nach berlin gab es war er
dann am tag danach hat sich also die
ganze grandiosität der stunde gezeigt in
dem der senat von mumbai auf der einen
seite und die cdu auf tatsächlich das
dritt nicht zu einer gemeinsamen
kundgebung aufgenommen
die cdu war dann an der gedächtniskirche
war erstmals am rad ja da bin ich zum
rathaus und da habe ich die versammlung
linken von berlin aus getriebes jaffa
nicht ging
da im moment rief doch komplette reifen
nicht in dem moment ich das fordern
während ich redete nämlich ordentlich
ausgepfiffen worden ein bild das in der
ganzen welt fußballs schaden angerichtet
war das übertragen wurden und war nach
bei mama diesen elenden verpackt es geht
nicht um wiedervereinigung sondern es
geht um wieder sehen und dass ich von
wiedervereinigung gesprochen habe das
dann in dem moment die dichte
beschreibung ich ausgepfiffen wurde und
während wir dann kassieren
auf dem balkon stand nahm schöneberger
rathaus hat gorbatschow
sowohl verdi als auch verbrannt
rückfragen gehalten angerufen ob es
stimmt und das war schon ein
entscheidendes tun die vielleicht
entscheiden ob es stimmt das was der
staat im fall der kgb im einreden wollen
das wie 53 zur wenige einrichtungen
soldaten gefährdet sein dass sozusagen
einen volksaufstand aller 56 ungarn oder
so was los wir haben dann
intensiv und das war sicherlich ein
glücksfall dass er inzwischen an
vertrauen zeit ist hatten ihn beschworen
das nicht so glaubt nun hat die soldaten
in den kasernen gelassen was passiert
wäre wenn sowjetische panzer an den
checkpoints stalin charlie gefahren
werden wäre vor allem gewesen dass die
ganze welt erkennt kann erkennen musste
dass die demarkationslinie des potsdamer
abkommens immer noch gilt furchtbaren
wirkung nach jeder seite gott sei dank
ist es anders gekommen seien
anschließend vor weit über
hunderttausend schöneberger rathaus und
habe dann in der nacht mit zwei paar
mittlerweile ein übergelaufen und
jetzigen an der siegessäule mit der
nacht zum 3 ein ganzer gruppen aus
ostberlin plötzlich erkannt betont hat
mit paar mitarbeitern allein und es
waren unglaubliche szenen mussten sie
dann passwort zeichnen sich übergangen
oder gar nix wird dazu die grenze war
hinüber
geladen sind römern über gerannt ist die
posten haben die steirer konnten und
salutiert und das bestraften eine ganze
weile bis zu dem als wir das
brandenburger tor flügen und der
oberbacher gemeint fans gemeldet dem
bundeskanzler keine besonderen
vorkommnisse das sind unvergessliche
erinnerung
wenig später habe polen zurück dieter
bohlen zu gast dann wieder nach
deutschland und andere überlegt was sie
machen und haben dann diesen
zehn-punkte-plan ausgearbeitete gibt es
zwei verschiedene darstellungen tätig
sie waren in oggersheim
darunter geschickt ein und korrigiert
zurück sie doch auch die darstellung
dass ihre frau dann die korrigierte
fassung in oggersheim selber gekippt hat
sie war sich also wie es eben war
wir haben wir heftig diskutiert und
haben 20 unterschiedliche meinungen
der ausgangspunkt war es war natürlich
die füße situation entstanden die immer
darf nicht vergessen werden auf dieser
dinge liefert das entscheidende nämlich
die abrüstungsgespräche zwischen
washington und zwischen moskau
wir tun ja so als eine der nabel der
welt ihr war nach damals sich dann aber
der welt und in dieser situation hinein
kam ja auch dann zunehmend stimmung aus
dem westen muss es jetzt sein und für
mich war klar was man irgendetwas tun
müssen so entstand die idee eine
regierungserklärung abzugeben
und dann war natürlich das problem an
bonds bis zum heutigen tag den vier
zusammensitzen steht deswegen stücken
später in irgendeiner zeitung
alles was wir darüber redeten war im
blick auf internationale öffentlichkeit
nicht geeignet zumal wir ja noch selber
nicht wissen ich jedenfalls nicht wusste
in details abkommen werden
und dann hat er dazu zählt natürlich
recht haben dem entwurf gearbeitet aber
denn eigentlich den dorf hat meine frau
oder reiseschreibmaschine zufrieden
deswegen richtet ja auch nicht raus und
an den mittag haben allein für ein organ
allein um ein gesprächspartner war dann
der kollege schon war ich über das thema
föderalisierung der völkerrechtlichen
beziehung wird genug bist du noch kein
material haus hatte
gross ein anerkannter für bereich
gewonnen habe ich ihn nicht was dich
begleiten wird in berlin oder in münchen
erreicht und immer wieder fragen
gestellt dann aber wieder zurückgerufen
aber nach der art eines studenten als
officer bei uns an den quellen
vorgearbeitet das hat sich dieses wort
konfigurationen nicht lieben ja ja ja
und stanzen wir am nächsten tag eine
miese stimmung bei alle mich fragten was
sagt denn um ich hab gesagt ich sage
nichts vorher weil das eben eine ganz
schwierige sache war
und da darf ja nicht vergessen sie die
ganze zeit von dem was bei uns passiert
in den oder was gorbatschow gemacht ist
aber die wahrheit war doch das
gleichzeitig unserer westlichen freunde
ich spreche nicht von den amerikanern
überhaupt nicht auf dem dampfer war
nicht nur sie mir den deutschen einheit
5 in großbritannien kondome jono lesen
zweimal am ethik geschlagen gibt sind
sie wieder da und der front meter raum
war heftig in zweifel zieht hier später
ein ganzes buch am ende seiner amtszeit
beschrieben um darzustellen dass er
eigentlich dafür war in diesem arriva
nicht dafür aber hin und hergerissene
auf der einen seite war schon klar dass
das ein undankbarer zustand ist erfolgt
auseinander zu reißen aber für die
französische politik für die skater sein
zustand er war nicht so weit von tropico
entfernt und der marca zerbrach war gar
nichts zu sagen hat ja offen gesagt dann
haben sie die damalige paar wochen
später die damalige niederländische
regierung vorgeschickt an die verlangte
friedenskonferenz stattfindet etwa das
ganze vergessen können alle krieg
führende messe der privatsender knapp
mehr als 110
der ganze reihe davon die letzten zehn
tagen den krieg erklärt haben ich weiß
jetzt plötzlich gegen hit wenn die da
sind sondern weil die patente gestohlen
haben ist es oft ich bin so ein freier
tag nicht möglich
darüber reden und deswegen war das ganz
wichtig als wir dann im noch im oktober
dezember in straßburg an die egk das war
in meiner ganzen laufbahn in europa die
journalistin die ich erlebt habe für
mich beim team für seine band regionales
war das war der normale eu-gipfels
normale vorsitz der vom toten
normalerweise wert ist eine gute sache
gewesen gut essen trinken und der besten
bindet sie mir daran gekommen wie die
angeklagten wieder ausnahme von philipp
konnten ist der einzige in europa
gewesen und jacques delors die immer zu
uns halten und sagt ich muss sagen dass
dieser recht waren alle anderen also
zwischen eiskalt wir wissen bisher
frostig und ablehnend und es war eine es
ging die angst einfach oben das darf er
nun auch nicht vergessen dass eben viele
glaubten jetzt gehen die ab jetzt kommen
die neutralisierung der bundesrepublik
hinaus der nach des vereinten
deutschlands die gene aus der nato rat
in dem auf der naa barras ist die
europäische gemeinschaft kaputt alles
war umsonst
die angst die schon umsatz her geführt
worden gut dann muss man noch für die
nächsten wochen war eine fieberhafte
tätigkeit ich habe sie immer nur mit
gedrückter mietraum trifft sich mit
margaret thatcher dass die nicht den
rosenkranz gebetet haben und im takt es
war auch ziemlich wie clara vorher noch
beck in kiew moskau seiner wiederwahl in
kiew bei gorbatschow oder an haben die
polen wo sie nur ihnen damit eine ganz
andere frage hereingebrochen die ganz
ganz bitter war
wir hatten ja wie man die deutsche
politik bis hin zum
bundesverfassungsgericht die these
vertreten
potsdam ist kein abschließendes urteil
die territorialen grenzen der bono sowie
deutsche versand friedensvertrag gelöst
das haben wir immer gesagt und nach
erweitert auch klar es gibt in
absehbarer zeit im friedensvertrag
wärmer mit leben können
mir nicht gedacht dass morgen diese
chance bekommen aber wenn dann im 1990
beginn 90 vom friedensarbeit geredet
werden
das tor war für ein paar monate fenster
war für ein paar monate auf das ist
heute ganz einfach feststellbar
beweisbar
da werde sie überhaupt nichts geworden
und stattdessen mussten wir halt eben
sehen wie kommen wir jetzt hin und dann
brach natürlich lieber realität
deutschlands und europas über unser
reiben die oder-neiße-grenze da haben
sie sicher sehr lange drängen lassen
janina vorgeworfen sie hätten es gemacht
und sozusagen den republikanern stehen
zu nehmen ich habe das gemacht um eine
mehrheit zu haben die die damals auf und
einredeten hatten ja die situation nicht
wir hatten 1945 ergebnis jetzt schon die
nazis vom zaun gebrochen und zweiten
weltkriegs ein titel ein drittel des
deutschen reichsgebiet verloren
nicht irgendein gelände das die nazis
geraubt hatten
königsberg und breslau und kann niemand
sagen dass das die städte waren die
traditionell eine die der deutschen
geschichte und den deutschen leben der
geschichte aufs engste verbunden waren
es waren über zwölf millionen menschen
ihr land wie irland haus der hof der
heimat verloren hatten
die sich seiner ungeheuer bittere
erfahrung für millionen menschen gewesen
die sich ja noch bis zum heutigen tag
bei vielen natürlich wussten wir ja auch
wir grenzen in europa infrage
stellungsspiel bitte frieden zwar klar
aber für mich war klar dass ich die oder
neiße die anerkennung der oder neiße
grenze verbinden muss gegenüber den
vertriebenen vielen anderem mit der
frage bist du das bank eine demagogische
nennen aber ich bekenne mich dazu dass
beim eine entscheidende frage in der
eigenen bundestagsfraktion
rich diesen massiv entgegen war dies
aber nicht machen
für mich ganz einfach dann sachen macht
ihren antrag die bundestag dessen gegen
die öffnung für 17 millionen deutschen
fan deutschland und wir akzeptieren
dafür die oder nahezu könnte nicht oder
er sagt wir sollen mit 17 millionen
zusammenleben und dafür zahlen wir den
preis für geschichte wie der oder neiße
grenze
und wenn sie mich fragen was eine
meisterleistung war dann glaube ich als
die abstimmung über die oder neiße im
deutschen bundestag war war es weniger
frontzeck stimmen die dagegen waren es
immerhin ein abschied deutscher
geschichte beendet und ich überhaupt die
möglichkeit gebracht
die ja so schnell sagt ihr müsst ich
habe immer gesagt ich gebe mein wort
ossi es mache aber den zeitpunkt müssen
wir schon selbst bestimmen und dann war
es ja auch kein thema sie haben vorhin
erzählt dass du ein großer angst gab das
gespürt haben straßburg von deutschland
geht aus dem westlichen bündnis heraus
sie haben dann im frühjahr vor dem
gipfel der dann in berlin stattfand mit
hoher gesagt lasst uns zusammen einen
brief schreiben dass wir jetzt den
einheitsprozess schneller machen und
mitterdorf angesprungen dabei besonders
glücklich war er immer für die
gemeinsame währung war die sie nicht
unbedingt so stark vertreten kann man
eigentlich damit sagen dass der euro die
preis für die deutsche anna heim das ist
alles für ganz falsch was man sagen kann
ist heute nur ein teilaspekt bedarf
sicher hieß die devise schneller
entwickelt hat der uns jungen immer
eingebläut habt deutsche einheit und
europäische einigung sieht zwei seiten
der gleichen medaille und es gab eine
geschichte glücksfall dass wir die die
medaillen kunden und beide seiten
betrachten kommen die deutsche einheit
und die europäische einigung ist es
überhaupt keine frage
dass die deutsche einheit nicht
vertragen worden wäre von unserer
nachbarn oder den entscheidenden schritt
zu schnellen einigung was dann zu den
verträgen für die europäische einen um
schneller vorangebracht haben und wie
brücken denke ich ist es ja auch die
einzige vernünftige politik denn wenn es
uns nicht gelingt die ostgrenze
deutschlands ist die oder neiße grenze
in einem zustand zu bringen wie heute
die westgrenze ist zwischen
rheinland-pfalz oder oder fahrland oder
paten zu frankreich ist kein frieden
geben die oder muss wenigstens den
ablauf einer generation in einer
situation seien der oder raum wie heute
wenn sie von straßburg nach kehl gehen
oder umgekehrt
sie gehen über eine staatsgrenze sich in
mitten in europa das ist fakt ist es
wichtig dass frieden bedeute ich möchte
noch auf den euro kommen die franzosen
für die weite besonders wichtig
sozusagen die haben ja von dem diktat
der bundesbank häufiger gesprochen und
den war es ganz wichtig das zu nehmen
was sie als deutsche identität sagen
nämlich die d-mark die deutschen
einbinden
sie haben ja lange zeit gezögert die sie
nach gehe man aber hier haben sie
nachgegeben
ich habe gezögert weil wir die
reihenfolge richtig war
das wird sicherlich sehr rasch zeiten
der euro legt jan und das will man fünf
jahren plant geben jetzt wirklich da ein
zahlungsmittel apathisch da liegt ja nun
schonungslos die schwächen jeder
europäischen volkswirtschaft offen
auch ich möchte diesen unserer
volkswirtschaft gibt aber abendländer
weglassen gibt es noch kreuzungen und
nach einiger zeit gab's jahr in
frankreich wird sich die these dass wir
dem euro ist ja schön und gut aber jetzt
hat die bundesbank alles übernommen und
es hat sich jedoch gezeigt als das
sozusagen die satzung der bundesbahn
bezieht zimmert wohnten die das alles
was über diesen verdienst von theo
waigel war
ist das alles in einer unglaublichen
kleider weit durch zu bohren
toller unterstützung von einer reihe von
leuten wie etwa den italienischen fans
vista den kollegen jumpy einer der ganz
großen auf diesem feld dieser erde
brachte
das hat das hat uns ein gutes stück
weiter gebracht
aber nicht jeder der dann für den europa
hat erkannt dass der euro europa
verändert an diesem punkt und dann kam
ja die lage probe bei der bank und das
muss ich ihnen schon sagen das gehört zu
meinen unvergesslichen stunden als alle
tisch anguckten nach aussagen stumm vor
sich hin gucken uns war klar haben
diesen tag wird entschieden und der
fonds anbieter raum als zweitletzter
dann sagte alle gründe aufzählen warum
eigentlich der die europäische
zentralbank nach paris muss aus seiner
sketche ein grund und dann aber gesagt
hat am ende
es hat ihr niinimaa frankreich stimmt
für frankfurt für den bundeskanzler und
noch viel schwieriger war ja der hat
keine lange rede garten der britische
premierminister zur messe und der hat
auch gesagt das ist dass ich gar keinen
zweiten gibt und kann dass die bank nach
london - kreis gibt nur nach new york
nur ein zweites zentrum und und und und
sorgt aber da die d-mark die wichtigste
währung ist und weil für deutschland die
die mag eine besondere bedeutung hat aus
der geschichte der bundesrepublik stimmt
crosby des vereinigten königreichs ohne
amtliche formulierung für frankfurt es
war eine große stille und viele haben
bei uns überhaupt nicht kapiert was da
passiert es langfristig
ein paar kommunale idioten in frankfurt
als erstes mal gesagt werden die
wohnungspreise die mietpreise steigen
ist eine sehr idiotische reaktion zu der
man sonntags am weg sind aber was das
auf die dauer bedeutet haben vielen
wirklich begriffen
in fünf jahren will das schon ganz
anders aus nun gab es ja einen zweiten
punkt etwas darum ging den ersten
präsidenten der europäischen zentralbank
zu ernennen und zurzeit von beta rang
schiesst es immer sie haben mit mit mühe
gemacht man das immer behauptet orten
wie das übrigens nirgendwo hinterlassen
wer das hinterlasse wäre es auf gebracht
hat weiß ist in paris aufgebracht
drei stars innenpolitischen es gab kein
versprechen über den präsidenten das als
der presse die präsidentenfrage kam hat
die rieti franzosen einen anderen
kandidaten sind natürlich alles
verwischt worden ob sie die bagger auf
brauche ich ein ganz anderer name
genannt worden erst am ende haben die
franzosen den kandidaten fallen lassen
das war das sehr schwierig sehr bitteren
ab übrigens ganz unnötige diskussion
das war keine meisterleistung der
eu-präsidentschaft das waren damals die
briten allerdings zum ersten mal aber
ein schwieriges feld des französischen
gern natürlich wir sind bei dem punkt
konnte man von konnte mich fragten warum
sind sie am montag nach der wahl nach
paris gefahren der grund ist ich habe ja
gesagt
die kombination ist eine sache und das
wär das nicht respektiert soll einfach
ausführen europäische politiker deswegen
muss man sich ja nicht banken ist eine
ganz andere angelegenheit
und im übrigen finde ich das was wir
gemacht haben ist glücksfall
wir haben eine ezb präsident sein
die verantwortlichen sprechen
zentralbank das ist das beste was wir in
europa zu bieten haben angefangen vom
präsidenten aber ich nehme mal die
frühere präsidentin der finnischen
nationalbank
der frau sei ein novum die dadurch
exzellente leute wie sie währung ist
sind ihre sachen in deutschland schon
gar nicht nach den erfahrungen mit zwei
installationen legen denn dann kann ich
in jeder normale deutsche wäre dass wir
künstlich aufrecht und trafen das ist
ein sehr beruhigendes gefühl
dazu ist zu kommen eben weil sie gesagt
haben ist unglaublich wichtig dass wir
den einigungsprozess in europa
vorantreiben
beim einigungsprozess in deutschland gab
sich erst mal die währungs einigung und
scheut ist kritisiert worden eine markt
zu einheit wird viel wären sie bereit
ein bisschen selbstkritisch darüber
nachzudenken wie alt habe ich auch genug
getan ich komme zum gleichen ergebnis
also wenn wir ihn hier in einem seminar
diskussion eines erstklassig geführten
lehrstuhls für finanz- wirtschafts- und
finanzpolitik eintreten weil die relativ
rasch einräumen sie haben recht
aber ich habe ich in einem solchen
seminar ich war in der lippe mit weitere
schäuble mit den anderen in der
lebendigen wirklichkeit deutschlands ich
war in ein land in dem ich ihn kam sieht
hier immer dieses beispiel besonders
gern am flugplatz in leipzig als
bestattete einmal mehr schwer dauern
damals viel unterwegs des riesen
transparenz gegen helmut weil die d-mark
dich nach leipzig kommen dann gehen die
leipziger zur d-mark und sie haben ja
gemacht
viele gerne vergessen wie viele
plötzlich über nacht einfach gelaufen
sind und gesagt wir bleiben hier nicht
erstens die machen wieder neue anfragen
scarpia zetsche ließ der deutschen
politik sollte tötet ist als für die das
gab die sagten bis wir wieder die grenze
zu machen obwohl es gab wird diese
freien vom von genomischen her
betrachten kann man die meinung
vertreten
aber die politische wirklichkeit war
doch
der sowieso das problemfeld ist alte
bundesrepublik alte ddr was die bürger
betrifft die politische wirklichkeit war
das so dass eine andere entscheidung in
den neuen ländern angekommen wäre um
eine bestärkung des vorwurfs des sowieso
bald wird die respektieren und für
lebensleistung nicht ja nicht umsonst
gelebt wir waren genauso fleißigen von
quoka oder wie die in form von meinen
aber ein bestimmtes ruhig jemand uns um
die früchte unserer arbeit gebracht sind
jetzt fast zehn jahre vorbei und es ist
viel passiert normalität ist es nicht
gekommen seid
es ist normal wenn wir eines tages da
drüben eine partei wie die pds haben die
eine normale partei nur ein beschluss
nicht normal was die nicht mehr geben
wird
das ist keine dauer erscheinung das sind
ewig gestrigen
die halten sich auf rechts zu einem zwei
junge leute sind auf einer protest
situation rasierter konkreten situation
junger leute dort entstanden ist
und dann gibt es leute die halt eben
nützlicher des regimes waren die in der
tat was verloren haben das ist ja wahr
was ja auf kosten anderer leute das
betrieben haben
ich bin da gar nicht so die werden
überhaupt nicht schon sehr viel
schneller eingebrochen
wenn sie nicht aus der weste
unterstützung bekommen dauer der sache
bin ich plötzlich diese normalität
besteht darin dass sie verschwinden wenn
man ihre kanzlerschaft sieht dann ist da
sehr viel passiert wir haben angefangen
mit der raketenstationierung die hat zum
ende des kalten krieges mit beigetragen
es kam die deutsche einheit also große
welt politischen veränderungen in
ihrer zeit als politiker 25 jahre lang
cdu-vorsitzender haben sie die cdu sehr
stark verändert es ist in deutschland
auch sehr vieles anders geworden
aber man fragt sich heute es wäre
wahrscheinlich sinnvoll gewesen gewisse
dinge in unserer gesellschaft system
vielleicht unserem sozialstaat zu
verändern
das hat nicht geklappt ist es deutschen
schwierig reformen durchzuführen
natürlich immer schwierig reformen
durchzuführen
schauen sie mal andere länder haben wenn
sie jetzt nicht die propaganda nehmen
wollen sagt ich mache reformen sondern
wirklich gucken was macht er für
reformen
dann kommt es natürlich auch das
wahlsystem an lozina meer und watt
system haben wie groß begangen wo
praktisch nur regieren können und dort
mit einer abgeklärt oder ob eine
koalition machen wollen das fed
wahrscheinlich weil ich nicht früher
weiß dieser mann und 24 jahren bin ich
nicht bei dieser mann wissen sie ich
weiß nicht das kommt ja auch 19
jahrhundert und das lebensgefühl von
unzähligen entspricht nicht dem das
einst das 50,1 alles haben 59,9 gar
nicht haben ich habe zweifel ob es
richtig ist
spieler und zwar ob sich das system held
etlicher weltweit auf dem rückzug
aber es ist jedenfalls die unseren
breiten rand hätte das niemand mehr
rauskommen drüber reden ist verlorene
zeit
neid ist die partie so dass die das
regieren aus einem anderen grund sei es
schwieriger geworden ist geschafft dass
sich beklagen den beklagen ton sondern
realität
wir haben die lage das natürlich bei
jedem schritt vor den tickern ungeheure
publizität entsteht und dass bei quasi
das was einfach notwendig ist einfach
mal einen gedanken haben ohne schon zu
wissen ob das richtig ist dass zur
debatte zu stellen
wenn sie also jetzt beispielsweise sagen
was ihr niemand bestreiten können
dass wir ein überall des landes über 4
millionen die wachtel ergab dass die
zahl der geburten zurück die zahl der
leute älter wird dass jemand mit 28
jahren hochschule verlässt mit 60
bildern ruhestand gehen lebensjahr muss
waren es zwischen sechs und 77 16 jahre
pension dreißiger ausbildungen 46 jahre
auf der 31 jahren ertrag die rechnung
kann nicht aufgehen ist mathematik zu
studieren
aber wie kann ich jetzt dazu das ändern
dann folgt ihr zwangsläufig wieder
fragen wie kann ich es machen in der
medizin versorgung wie kann ich es
machen bei den krankenhausbetten in die
kinderzahl geht zurück die frage der
geriatrischen kliniken gewinnt an
bedeutung
aber wenn sie jetzt nur das nachdenklich
sagen haben sie doch die schlagzeile
sie schaffen die die geburtenstation ab
aber ein veritabler oberbürgermeister
samstag in meinem garten haus ist völlig
undenkbar dass diese station nicht da
ist und dass sie die für die erbse
sondern die ganze stadt sagt dass
kürzere unserer stadt und unseren club
card ist dass wir das haben oder dass
man sagt der der rentenanstieg so heißt
ja der formel darf nich anders sein als
der anstieg beim im lohnbereich wenn man
den wohnbereich das so jetzt wie es auch
war das kein anstieg war hebt sich die
frage warum steigt um vorräte dich das
heißt es ist ziemlich schwierig reformen
zu machen aber das form machbar
wir haben sicherlich und da diese wahl
verloren bei der bundestagswahl ist beim
bundestagswahlprogramm der union nicht
zu verändern
es ist die frage ob das über zu bringen
war das was da drin steht keine riesigen
opfer wenn sie wenn sie 30 urlaubstage
raten und wenn sie 12 feiertagen sind 42
plus samstag und sonntag kommt es auf
zwei monate urlaub gibt es nur ganz
weltlich
und dann verloren sie sich ob sie einen
tag im krankheitsfall darzubieten ich
war nicht wirklich des feiertags die
videos gerne gesehen und es ist glaubt
einer berg und verständliche frage warum
sich die tarifpartner nicht kennt erlebt
haben wenn sie mich fragen rein fehler
wirklich einer der feder will ich denn
dass ich nicht darauf gesagt hätte ihr
macht es selbst was ihr dann auch
gemacht haben
das ist erfahrungen sie wenn sie acht
wagen geschlagen haben sieben gewonnen
haben müssen sie zum kauf anderer hat er
gesagt werden auf einer politik gegessen
hat der will immer mehr davon essen
aber als sie die macht abgeben musste
hatte man den eindruck sie geben sie ab
und sagen das war er indes fotos wassers
was ich aussteigen
dann wird falls nein wissen sie darum
mit der gewissen gelassenheit ja aber
das will ich noch gerne begründen ersten
mal ich kenne kein gefühl blick zurück
sie können eine aufgabe übernehmen und
haben glück oder pech wickeln gar nichts
bewegen war alle tore zu sind ich habe
vor team nicht weil ich gut bin sondern
weil die gelegenheit so war in der wand
tour hoffen da kommt man durchgehen wenn
du sagen können dass das über lange zeit
gar nicht passiert und ich habe die
gelegenheit genutzt um das buswrack wort
zitiert
wenn der mann gottes deutsche geschichte
geht die zu springen shift alt aber ich
habe aber auch gleichzeitig das geld ja
nun in dieses bild hinein
vieles machen können was mich mit einer
tiefe befriedigung erfüllt und wenn sie
dann eine und unter druck musste auch
etwas mit würde zu tun wenn ein
bundeskanzler der geschlagen ist bei
werder war ein demokratischer vorgang
regierung von heute ist opposition von
morgen
gekehrt wenn wir keine worte mehr
ausstrahlt und zeigt und habt besser
sich haben ist doch das beispiel und es
war für mich sehr wichtig dass es dabei
deutlich wird nicht nach dem motto macht
euren dreck alleene nach den brücken
königs wort bei der absenkung sondern
nein das ist seine chance genutzt und
jetzt halt ein anderer die chance aber
ich bin doch kein abschied von der
politik
es würde sich nicht schämen wenn man
eine wahl verloren hat das maul
aufzureißen und über alles möglich er zu
ziehen
aber ich habe ein paar sachen den ich
besonders innerlich verbunden will
abgesagt nach der europawahl nicht
vorher gemacht keine hände an
weder für die europäische kommission
noch für ein reformprojekt berry kann
man die kommission reformierung alles
nichts davon aber ich werde mich im
rahmen einer internationalen
parteiarbeit nach der europa waren die
europa politik wieder massiv engagieren
weiteren verhandlungen was vieles
anderes und die sachsen gibt es eine
ganze menge was ich tun kann
ich finde beispielsweise was sie vorher
gesagt haben wenn man ein junger es hier
einfach machen dies ist eine der
bedingungen erfahrung der letzten monate
sei einfach viel kommen mit der horster
fraktion die haben den kanzler der kam
da rein in die fraktion niemals bekannt
war weit weg oder buddhisten die kommen
sie her
dann merken wir mal was der pergola jim
carrey hat mitzumachen kann mit dem man
normal reden kann und es macht mir
ausgesprochen freut und solange ich
gesund bleibe und meine lebensfreude
mehr halten kann
worauf ich hoffe dann mache ich das so
ich habe kein grund zurück im zorn zu
gucken
ich habe grund viel grund zur
dankbarkeit die persönlichsten bereich
gegenüber mai
familie meiner frau meinen kindern
meiner nächsten umgebung der mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter die wir jahrzehntelang
ertragen haben meine eigenen partei wie
mal mich höher gehalten hat man wieder
weniger hoch gehalten hat aber doch das
ist ja normal ich hab ja vielen leuten
auf die füße getreten laufen die hat
seinen manchmal mit genuss das hat mir
keine freundschaft das schafft manchmal
ohne es zu wollen
und ich finde dass ist das treten ich
kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen
dass ich anders reagiere ich jetzt
reagieren an meine wiege stand nicht
dass ich ministerpräsident
das ist bundeskanzler werde alles die
alle diese themen reden aber ich war 24
jahre alt und bundeskanzler 25 jahre
eine figur die an gewissen einzelnen der
partei hatte nur was eigentlich sollte
ich mich beschweren ich habe gar keinen
grundstücke ein grund dankbar zu sein
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler natürlich
recht hat
[Musik]
ich bin
und